so I view my job as first and foremost
being present for students here at
Harvard hula on campus usually six days
a week I come in on weekdays at 7:15 for
prayer services and often don't leave
until after dinner I eat dinner with
students of seven o'clock or eight or
nine depending on what programs were
running here at Hillel and the way that
interactor students really takes on many
different many different forms some of
it is helping to oversee our prayer
community or one the Orthodox prayer
community here at hello I study with
students so in the morning way after
services I teach a Talmud class I learn
I study one-on-one or students in what
we call a hover town model of study so
one on one study and that could be
anything could be something which is an
introduction to Judaism answering some
basic basic questions about Jewish life
it could be for more advanced students
delving into the Talmud or into the
Torah or Tanaka so the profits can be
examining different questions of Jewish
law or looking towards Jewish texts to
think about how they might inform our
lives and our life choices beyond that I
think I'm I'm here for Orthodox students
or more broadly for observant students
who have questions about Jewish practice
about Jewish observance and they may
turn to me as a rabbi to get guidance on
am I allowed to do X am I allowed to do
Y or what's a can I eat this food can I
not eat this food can attend this class
if it's on a Jewish holiday various
questions of Jewish practice of Jewish
law I also teach classes throughout the
week on usually on Tuesdays I teach at
lunch and learn so we'll serve pizza
here at Harvard Hillel
now teach at various topics about Jewish
life and also Thursday nights late at
night at 9:00 p.m. we have what we call
mish Mar which is sort of the way we cap
off the week we have chi'lan which is a
form of traditional Jewish stew and I
also teach a class then and more
generally I'm available for students in
terms of counseling so if students just
wanna what an idea by me if it's taking
a class or an issue that's going on in a
personal relationship or
something going on at home with their
parents how they're experiencing school
those are all things that I'm here and
to discuss with students really just to
be a open and listening ear to be
someone whom they can bounce ideas off
of either here at hello or take them out
for coffee or for ice cream and this can
be Jewish students or non-jury students
again the some of the questions that
students might be interested in
again Jewish or not could be just they
want to know some basics about what is
Judaism and so I'm here to answer those
questions